this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
on today's episode he's going to be
checking out the varied arsenal
of fallout 3. fallout is a weird always
a weird mixture of serious and
funny and i think that weapon sums it up
if there are any other games guns and
mechanics that you guys want to see
jonathan break down let us know in the
comments section below
make sure to subscribe for more videos
like this one and if you'd like to help
out the royal army's museum and continue
to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
right so one of my i'd say one of my
favorite games i haven't played it in
many years but
um put a lot of time in back in the day
and
one of my favorite weapons to use was
the chinese pistol
it's one of the more real world firearms
in the fallout series full stop
it's a very good approximation given the
limitations of the graphics
of the chansey type 17. all of which is
very sad because
we haven't got one we've got chinese
broom handles
one is a copy of the star and the other
is
this schnell foyer copy so that that's
as close as we get
to the chinese pistol now reason for
pointing that out is that they have
actually replicated the different
magazine well
shape of the type 17 because it's a
longer wider magazine to cram in those
45 acp
cartridges reload animation not accurate
even though the model is very accurate
the bolt should in theory
lock open there are some quirks of this
3d model
there's no firing pin modelled or even
um textured on there in 2d
so it wouldn't technically work and the
other weird quirk is we've got
rifle caliber cases flying out of this
thing even though we're putting pistol
caliber rounds in it via the clip
now the ak family we've covered many
times on this series
would have perhaps made narrative sense
to just for the fallout series for the
chinese
faction to stick with the ak why
wouldn't they well i suppose
the idea is that it was never invented
in the first place and so the
the russian rifle that was originally
invented in the timeline was something
different
however it's pretty obviously an ak
configured rpd
perhaps for me more interesting than
that and something i've forgotten about
this game
is the the fact that weapons degrade
over time
with use and they they have stoppages
but i have
i have had to wrangle many a chinese
assault rifle jamming
constantly in a way that doesn't really
do justice to the legacy of
uh kalashnikov or dektorov to be honest
with you but
it's really nice to have in a game
especially in a survival
type setting it really gives you that
idea of having to make doing mend couple
stuff together
abandon that weapon entirely and switch
to something else so i think it
really adds a lot to the game
so this um if we think about the the
sort of narrative of the
fallout universe everything sort of 50s
and
that would have been made 50s and
onwards is something a bit different
and this submachine gun machine pistol
are much more removed from reality i've
seen people compare this submachine gun
or machine pistol
to the hk smg prototype because it has a
similar silhouette maybe but it is
essentially a completely original design
quick word on vats because we do see in
this clip it used to it's
one of its best effects which is to
where you've got a high chance hit
on us on a particularly dangerous weapon
or the arm that's holding that weapon so
we see him target
that to take that weapon out of the
fight to then switch fire to something
else that's a very good use of the
system
i was always very lazy i would go for
high percentage hit on head and if i
couldn't i'd go for the
go for the torso
right the uh well we need a magnum
revolver in any video game
featuring firearms and we have the daddy
of them in fallout 3. it's
a pretty good representation of the
smith and wesson model 29
of dirty harry fame as i say pretty well
represented
there's a weird quirk but i think
applies to the whole game
where we see proper revolver bullets
loaded in
by speed loader into the cylinder but
then if you get a slo-mo
fancy shot the bullet you see fly
through the air is a pointed boat tail
rifle bullet
we've said this before about the fallout
series but it is a sort of mad max meets
wild west
so you've got to have a revolver some of
them are going to be reminiscent of the
peacemaker
the single action army some of them are
going to be more your classic
mid-century 20th century that is uh
magnum so
44 magnum revolvers i'm not sure that
quite fits with the timeline
of where the fallout universe diverges
from hours
but this came in in 1955
so it's if we if we take that as the
divergence point
none of this is strict we can't compare
the fallout universe two hours but
clearly at some point it split off so i
guess this one just sneaks in under the
wire
as common to both universes
right so this is um this is another
pre-apocalypse
gun that's in the game specifically
lincoln's fancy
repeater winchester it's nearly entirely
henry and they've even bothered to
render the loading system somewhat
correctly so the whole
end of the outer barrel just pivots out
of the way
and you load your rounds into the tube
below the magazine base first
couple of issues with the game version
though most obviously is the way the the
first person the animation well actually
all the third person just kind of
waggles their fingers in the vague
direction of the
magazine tube and all of your rounds
just somehow
go in that's a convenience or a fudge
the other one
is a stylistic choice so they've put a
wooden handguard
around the magazine tube near the action
but there's a reason why the henry the
1860 henry
did not have a handguard they didn't put
one on there because it gets in the way
of the loading system so the bit we're
missing here is the action of the
spring-loaded follower
that you need to position correctly
before you open the end of the magazine
tube so that has to move
through that wooden handguard so the
hand guard can't be there for that to
happen
otherwise it's not a bad attempt
at a henry with engraved receiver the
proportions are about right it's got
an octagonal barrel it does the job it
evokes the the
very prior era that it's supposed to
well first of all i need to say i
absolutely love the uh the railway
gun brilliant sort of comedy weapon
fallout is a weird always a
weird mixture of serious and and funny
and i think
that weapon sums it up completely
implausible completely impractical
who would make it i'm not sure if the
in-universe reason is that it is in fact
a tool for
planting rail railroad spikes into a
railroad that would make sense
i suspect that's the idea as a weapon
it's just amusing
it's got the uh the steam piston visible
on the bottom of it
it's got the steam gauge it produces
steam and it makes the hilarious
uh train whistle sound every time you
use it
it's it's realistic insofar as the
projectiles actually do look like
railroad spikes
when they come out it's it's a slightly
weird choice in the
uh fallout if anything is more sort of
atom punk
maybe a bit of diesel punk it's not in
any way a steampunk aesthetic
and yet this is the most steampunk
weapon ever invented arguably
yeah that that is not how magazines work
this is a fundamental misunderstanding
of what a magazine is
so this shotgun is basically a giant um
papashar ppsh whatever whatever you'd
like to call it
russian submachine gun scaled up to
12-gauge
12-ball shotgun cartridges okay the
issue with it is the drum magazine
positioned so far forward this
could could be made to work but then it
has a sort of an ejection port
further back than that no way for that
to operate
that's too small for a shotgun cartridge
there's no
hole in the drum when it's taken off the
weapon
for a cartridge to even come out of or
be fed into
so they've recognized that the drum is
in fact the feed device for the weapon
it's not just a decorative thing but
they haven't thought through
in any way how it might work the
geometry doesn't work either
we've got a weird redundant gas system
on there
this is a real mash up fantasy weapon
the amusingly named rocket launcher i
made very little
use of when i played this used it for
fun gave up
i'm not sure i found it super effective
and the different mass of the different
bits of junk it shoots
makes aiming a real pain and damage is
the same no matter whether you hit them
with a garden gnome
amusingly or a teddy bear or a tin can
the damage is the same
so i wasn't a huge fan great idea not
really that effective for me this
by request is what i've grabbed
to show you really to illustrate what is
it what is actually a myth
um this is a blunderbuss obviously this
is one of about
1730ish but the reason we're here
is that flared muzzle and the myth
suspect where the rocket launcher idea
comes from
is we do have stories of people putting
rocks nails random objects into these
because of course you can in theory put
anything into here
with a powder charge behind it prime
your lock and shoot it and it will come
out with potentially lethal force
depending on how you load it
but was that ever done historically
there's just no evidence for it
in reality if you could afford a
blunderbuss and to keep it in good order
you could afford
some lead shot and that's what was used
the important point is
yes you can load random stuff in a
blunderbuss no nobody did it as far as
we know
which leaves our poor rocket launcher
pretty much out on its own
as an improvised wood chipper based
weapon from a parallel universe
the base rifle here is very clearly
based on the hkg3
this version is particularly wacky it's
got a suppressor on it it's got no butt
stock it's got a scope on it so
a scope suppress rifle in a full power
cartridge well
let's say it's five five six then in an
intermediate cartridge even is
really an odd choice if you don't have a
bus stock so the reason for no butt
stock is something concealable
where you're using it very close range
now there are other factors in play here
probably in game play but
it's about as accurate as i would as i
would expect it to be
with a scope but no butt stock and
suppressor's probably a bit
too good as well for a rifle caliber
it's kind of
mechanical chuntering going on rather
than gunfire which
still sound pretty much like gunfire and
it's not really fitting my theory of
parallel universe divergence in the 40s
or 50s because
this really didn't come into service
until come into existence until the late
50s
but still we can probably massage it to
fit the timeline but yeah not a good
variant
right going really left field here and
of course the fallout universe does
flirt with aliens
and we've got this rare sort of
legendary level weapon that crops up in
a couple of the games don't know if this
was the first one to feature it or not
it's classically 30s 40s
raygun don't think it's based on any
particular toy or
film or anything like that it's their
own take on it can't help thinking about
mars attacks although
the guns in that work rather differently
and the pistol doesn't really look like
this
think of the classic buck rogers
disintegrated pistol from the
from the classic foo fighters album
cover that kind of thing
super effective as you might imagine
from alien technology
we've got a reload system with an energy
tube
thing in the side who cares how it works
really
doesn't really fit in the universe
really for me
but it's a fun one and you get the
disintegration aspect of it
and the sort of it does fit in terms of
the fiction
of the 1940s and 50s which fallout takes
heavily from and i guess that's how it
fits
but they've just taken the that leap of
yeah aliens did crash in 1947.
we've seen the fat the fat man in in
previous incarnation
we've got here the straightforward
missile launcher or frankly you could
just call it a rocket launcher the
typical differentiator of a missile
versus a rocket is a missile
is guided this is not guided it has some
redundant switchology on the sides
i love analog switches and lights and
things but um these i don't think
do much the real kind of where this
falls down if we're trying to fit this
into the real world
is that the thing breaks open like a
shotgun which is just
not the way to make a missile or rocket
launcher at all uh because
there's no reason to not load the
missile rocket
from the front or from the back or if
you think of the small
munition is part of the entire rear
receiver of the weapon essentially and
you just fit that fire it dispose of it
so semi-disposable
or you have a fully disposable system
where you just fire and
discard this is none of those this is
for some reason we have to
pivot it open in the middle in a really
cumbersome way that wouldn't be
practical but it makes it visually
different and interesting to watch i
suppose
although i'm a veteran fallout 3 player
i
never played any dlc so i'm not seen the
microwave emitter before
it's a lot of fun it fits that future
retro futuristic
radiation obsessed aesthetic very nicely
it's a terrible weapon though
it's not not been designed as a weapon i
would i suggest i don't know the back
story of the of this
thing but um you know we see that the in
third person view
the characters doing their best to sort
of aim jack bauer's style with something
that has
not only has no sight but blocks his
view
when he tries to aim it i like the the
sort of ray effects the
the rings that emanate from it and how
it has a battery instead of a magazine
more redundant switchology with the big
dial it doesn't do anything but it looks
cool
i suppose the only thing i can
contribute here really apart from
reacting
is for those of you who aren't aware
there is in fact a
microwavable or millimeter wave weapon
system called the active denial system
but this used
the closest thing we've seen to using a
micro millimeter wave radiation
to heat the target so it was nicknamed i
think the heat ray
vehicle mounted though and it didn't
look anything like this
disappointingly it's a shame how often
sci-fi-esque weapons
that are implemented in the real world
look nothing like their sci-fi
counterparts
okay we've got a variant of the fat man
that i don't think i ever
used when i played the game a sort of
shotgun version
so lots of small warheads instead of one
big
miniature nuclear bomb if that makes
sense because the original fat man
munition
was a scaled down airdrop nuclear bomb
like the
the fat man that we've covered before it
is in fact a steam catapult
or a gas catapult system so the in the
original concept it was
like a steam catapult on an aircraft
carrier for a miniature aircraft
carrying a comedically oversized nuclear
bomb so it's interesting to see how it
sort of drifted from that slightly
ludicrous
concept to something closer to that davy
recoilless weapon system that we know
was actually
tested but this one is that mirv or
multiple independent reentry vehicle
which is a a real thing for nuclear
missiles so this is riffing on that
but it is still firing miniature nuclear
bombs not nuclear missiles
i might have preferred actually
retrospect if they've gone for miniature
minuteman nuclear missiles or something
like that
out of a different launcher but hey um
it's still pretty cool and pretty
devastating
as well
you can also find me over on the royal
armouries youtube channel
we're welcoming visitors if you're in
the uk please do come and visit us
and we have links in the description for
ways that you can help us
otherwise i'll see you next time thank
[Music]
you
[Music]
you